six weeks ago Sam bankman freed was the
face of crypto today the Man known as
SPF is synonymous with catastrophic
failure and say U.S authorities a
multi-billion dollar fraud after he was
arrested in the Bahamas pending
extradition to face criminal charges
following the collapse of his
cryptocurrency trading platform FTX this
morning we unsealed an eight count
indictment charging Samuel bankman freed
ftx's founder with a series of
interrelated fraud schemes that
contributed to ftx's collapse I think
it's fair to say that by any anyone's
light this is one of the biggest
Financial frauds in American history
the executive handling ftx's bankruptcy
told Congress he'd never seen
mismanagement on this scale the FDX
group's collapse appears to stem from
absolute concentration of control in the
hands of a small group of grossly
inexperienced and unsophisticated
individuals
who failed to implement virtually any of
the systems or controlled that are
necessary for a company entrusted with
other people's money or assets
around 1 million FTX customers use
dollars pounds or other traditional
currencies to buy and trade
cryptocurrencies including Bitcoin and
ethereum prosecutors allege billions of
dollars in customer funds were secretly
funneled to Alameda research spf's
crypto hedge fund which made high risk
bets as well as funding lavish
properties and political donations
in just three years FDX built bankman
freed an estimated 26 billion dollar
Fortune with celebrity endorsements
including from supermodel Giselle adding
Glitz while former Prime Ministers and
presidents brought gravitas understand
this technology Revolution and harness
it for the public good to conferences
alongside a young man who seemed to
offer a glimpse of the future of Finance
Anthony scaramucci briefly spokesman for
president Donald Trump lost 10 million
dollars after SPF invested in his
company I'm past the anger stage as you
probably are aware I sold 30 percent of
my firm that I built over the last two
decades to Sam the good news is I didn't
sell more of it to him so but I'm past
the anger stage give a sense to our
audience of how serious the kind of
charges in here are wire fraud
um money laundering campaign Finance act
this is serious stuff right
yeah this is go away in prison a very
very long time I think Sam bankman freed
is looking for uh looking forward to 20
years to life it will take months or
years before ftx's customers discover if
they'll get any money back and historic
setback for an industry already short on
trust poor Kelso Sky News